a root canal or what
right now I can get you some oxygen
right now about a five I'm good man
thank you because it's addictive highly
addictive it is and there's a huge thing
going on in 1996 to like 2000 I mean
it's kind of stuff no but yeah but
Oxycontin was the thing it's huge it's
usually still going it's heroin fentanyl
is a hundred times I know a thousand
times stronger than morphine which is
even stronger than Oxycontin 100 times
even possible Oxycontin is a hundred
times more potent than morphine so
really yeah damn and so they oh dude
because I've been watching the thing you
know oh actually everything on it like I
watch painkiller then I watch dope
second then I watched the documentaries
I saw all this [__] but man it is so
crazy that they thought dude there's a
time release
thing it's yeah I know yeah and they
were like well the good thing is the
dose doesn't go into you
it goes into your it releases as you
need it for 12 hours right but dude you
put it in your mouth and you swallow it
and then it releases do people were just
snorting it yeah and that obviously
that's a way to get Beyond it okay
is that obvious I guess I wouldn't it is
when somebody decides to do it and then
they just spread the information right
okay you know the company's new dude
that [__] that it blows my mind dude
okay but you know what I mean Oxycontin
but we're doing this now and I'm just
saying but Oxycontin is crazy how that
[__] went as far as I control now it's
fentanyl yes did you ever see the videos
of the cop that are like let's see what
we got here they open a bag and then
they're just like are those real I hate
when people say that but I've seen that
and I don't know if those are real a
fentanyl a little piece of fentanyl go
like it's like the uh Forest gum feather
you're just at the park
playing with your kids
[Music]
you know why did we blend those together
[Laughter]
why are those together I know I know
what else floats the bag in American
Beauty you could pick whatever you want
but dude a [__] dope fiend dude in
the park in a library three they don't
even use libraries anymore three blocks
away
[Music]
this guy over here outside the cuckoo
gets lucky
just talking to his friends
and they brush
that's not what happened dude you know
what I mean if that happened it would
never be made ever you know what
happened to my kid it's not gonna happen
no three blocks away outside the library
no a milligram of fentanyl can kill you
though for sure see if you don't use it
ever if you've never used it before well
a kid never uses it your kid a kid a kid
oh I see what you're saying that's not
what happens though it doesn't float
through the air and then go into his
nose and then he dies which is not this
is not a thing